all right Peppa it's your boy second
pebble guess I haven't got enough for
this game because now we're gonna do so
after you eat the game as usual in last
video it says like now for like an
extended story go collect all the family
albums and they gave this hint was 666
so I think we had to go to each picture
and get like the animal so if you look
at this one I put in the code right
there
right what is that and they gave me this
um and their shapes okay so he's the
first one I dunno when I click on it
yeah because I gotta find out what
everything is so oh great
um there is crow okay I was gonna write
these down will fortune
okay queen of Pentacles and there's a
there's an order one two three four two
four one okay
death hello okay
oh okay so there actually is a pattern
to do okay
they show symbols can't strike without
line one bird goes circles that way goes
this way and this way nothing that must
be Albert oh yes yes yes yes yes okay
perfect perfect way up
just take a picture of each one
okay the star
and I think we just need two more wait
the hangman are not the Hermit
crow and yes yes okay I think we got
them all
I got one yeah see this is that okay um
guess we're gonna marry is very even
have one
[Music]
wait no this is Mary this is Emma
the one for mmo's the Pentacles and that
was the one with the numbers so it's
three oh three for two for one
with the heck
3 4 2 1 4 then it's happening check
either way 3 4 2 1 4 isn't it
wait whoa whoa whoa right
four two one
four three four - oh I messed it up
three four - four one can try the
backwards one three four two four one
why is this not working
[Music]
it doesn't work it does work
what the heck okay let's get out here
closer there Emma
oh this is it okay three four
- four okay so that was Emma
where's Albert he's the birds no no he's
not the birds Chan was the birds
no lenders the birds okay stripe goes
here circle goes here
single-line goes here you bring the
click it again there we go
okay psychic she was death is Leonard
you Frank
the hangman
no the Hermit he's it was crowing and a
symbol
mhmmm okay this is the hand holy crap
not got back to Emma nope
back to Mary
one two three four
[Music]
okay how do we not have yeah no you
don't have Albert's thank you is the
devil by the second side
he had these symbols this this yes but
the Empress had it upper the heck is the
Empress I don't know how they oppress us
there's a three and a triangle I got em
up maybe Ines Deborah's
huh can I click on that you click on
that you can't click on the see there
yeah there's other way out of the way oh
the Empress is this okay so they give
some of it who starves X or that I think
they gave death is this hangman says
that we could get lucky
just try this
[Music]
I said that probably more don't seem you
know I can't Albert
no I don't have Samuel
now he's probably that word clock one
time G with the clock
I think it was this he moves the other
way
anger that were huh
okay um yes yep gets 10:35 and I still
need I don't have Rosie's
[Music]
live
alright let me go back now your are the
symbols ok wait one sec oh sure is that
crow again
[Music]
oh wait there are more cards
don't say anything
the lovers
okay
[Music]
who uh since nice give it a clown oh
wait
tell Rose the letters in the names we
are all these young what do you feel
drummer
[Music]
tell Rose the letters in the names
[Music]
r1 l1 table rows the letters in names
amps xu1
the letters in the names I'm guess it's
good arose
[Music]
what is our
[Music]
as ours one at Hell's one
uh-huh
had only two ones I was just two words R
and L not me was just rusty link
[Music]
and you clear
[Music]
yep okay reasonably soon the itis and
that one gear was all of it huh
stars definitely this
the hangman is definitely this
wait no the Hermit says I didn't even
finish it
okay this is a new level
yeah it's a new level okay hello brother
hello brother Brad and she like died
here fire earth can I combine them
but Oh is my just making like every
possible combo
okay I'm done
you know things to do anything yeah
why salsa fading Jesus metrics and stuff
con powder
don't seen this a whole game hang in
like a bottle
can you tell what this stuff is
have a plan here I get a phase
it's lifts the only things that go into
any direction shell
I don't what desk
so chunk
campaigner
don't pray that mixed with anything
don't I guess don't go with anything at
all
it's y'all forging it what times
electricity
a fossil
shock
just maybe going for the color this will
make the egg rent
yeah okay
I not done yet
there's too many combos like I'm
actually like confused a little bit
that make sense
Santos ain't electricity
huh am I done
meet the elixir
why isn't it I thought its electricity
and sand that make like glass yeah bro
you drink first brother sure thing nice
to a thigh half weight they just died
I just died
i mean ii monitors going crazy
okay Sara moms don't walk bunker
oh no I dragon he returned the crown is
that turned into the tree
why don't with the egg oh thank our
waited huh that's it
okay well I guess that's that thanks for
watching y'all thanks a lot yeah I guess
it's true that she becomes tree
great thanks